[Musique]
Véronique prince José Legault Michel
David bonsoir bonsoir je disais d'entrée
de jeu au début de l'émission que ça un
peu volé la vedette du sujet politique
de la journée en cette rentrée
parlementaire à Québec l'affaire el
ghaouahabi je vais vous faire écouter
donc le résumé de la journée on revient
tout de suite en parler
j'appuie 100%
elle est en train elle a démontré tout
au long de ces années de travail une
sensibilité une ouverture et une rigueur
dont on a besoin maintenant je comprends
que faire face à l'islamophobie ça va
exiger des conversations importantes et
parfois difficiles mais on a besoin de
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît qui a ancré à
fond et je sais que c'est la bonne
personne
monsieur Trudeau en la gardant en poste
il vient cautionner le mépris envers les
Québécois moi j'en viens pas j'en viens
pas que Monsieur Trudeau nous dit qu'il
appuie à 100% après tout ce qu'elle a
dit après tout le même prix que le
montrer envers les Québécois
tourne quelques heures j'imagine que ils
vont apprendre à acte au Parti libéral
du Canada au gouvernement je sais que le
député par le Rodriguez le lieutenant du
gouvernement libéral le lieutenant
québécois a exprimé son malaise donc moi
j'espère que l'information va percoler
un moment donné jusqu'à au bureau du
premier ministre du Canada qui va
reconnaître son erreur
et ça fait des années que le
gouvernement fait diversion sur le dos
des minorités moi je trouve ça vraiment
déplorable comme stratégie ça dure ça
dure ça dure et ça se voit de
l'abstention des solidaires
elle les a clarifié brièvement on a
besoin d'en entendre plus moi j'aimerais
on souhaite entendre une rétractation
plus claire plus complète de ses propos
et c'est la raison pour laquelle mon
collègue va la rencontrer
bon là vous avez tout eu si vous étiez
pas là au début Véronique on a bien
résumé les positions de chacun Québec
solidaire qui dit puis monsieur Boisy
dit ah on prend prétexte sur cette
histoire là encore pour taper sur les
sur les immigrants sur les musulmans or
il y a d'autres choses à faire
ça vraiment dominé la journée à Québec
dans les corridors et c'est le sujet
politique c'était ça mais quand Québec
solidaire dit que ça fait diversion ben
force et de constater que c'est vrai
qu'on a moins de parler du système de
santé aujourd'hui on a moins parlé aussi
d'un autre départ Hydro-Québec mais en
même temps Patrice c'est une carte
payante pour le gouvernement le goût le
filon comme ça de dire mais on se
laissera pas insulter on est un peuple
fier
c'est de dire qu'encore une fois
finalement il faut se défendre la carte
du nationalisme du défenseur de la
nation québécoise c'est un filon que
François Legault a toujours exploité en
même en 2018 ça lui a permis de se
démarquer finalement de Philippe
Rouillard qui était davantage perçu
comme un puis dès qu'on est capable de
jouer cette carte là moi je sais ces
gens-là vont prendre là vous se
reconnaître même si je les nomme pas il
y a les gens au bureau du premier
ministre qui regarde ça en se frottant
les mains puis en se disant parfait on
va le jouer il y avait un but ouvert
puis on lance on laissera pas l'occasion
il y avait un bus ouvert
donc les propos d'Elga Wahbi donnait une
occasion José êtes-vous d'accord pour
refaire une montée en disant on se
laissera pas marcher sur les pieds là
puis on n'est pas comme ça les Québécois
etc
oui mais ça n'empêche pas non plus que
sur le fond de la question même si c'est
payant politiquement le premier ministre
du Québec a raison donc c'est aussi
payant en politiquement pour Monsieur
Trudeau soit dit en passant cette
nomination là ça fait le payer
politiquement à l'extérieur du Québec
donc chacun joue son électorat mais là
c'est de savoir qui met le doigt sur le
vrai bobo et quelque part je pense que
quicon connu pas seulement le fameux
écrit de la dame de 2019 dans leur
tabacitoine qu'elle avait consigné mais
l'ensemble de son œuvre l'ensemble de
ses écrits sur la question de la loi 21
au Québec et son point de vue est très
clair pour elle la majorité des
Québécois et il serait habité là de
sentiment anti-musulman ça ça s'appelle
de l'islamo phobie le sentiment
anti-musulman et elles sont rôles dans
ces nouvelles fonctions
c'est de combattre ça alors comment
voulez-vous qu'elle puisse combattre des
préjugés contre un groupe identifiable
les Canadiens musulmans quand
elles-mêmes depuis des années nourrit
des préjugés à l'encontre de notre
groupe identifiable c'est-à-dire les
Québécois et pour être plus précises les
Québécois francophones parce qu'on
comprend que c'est bien deux dont elle
parle lorsqu'elle parle de la majorité
de Québécois et lorsqu'elle a dit
qu'elle s'était fier avec sondage je
m'excuse Michel l'esprit très bien dans
sa chronique ce matin ben le tronquille
les résultats de ce sondage là donc en
plus c'est faux donc parfois oui on peut
jouer à un jeu politique et en même
temps avoir raison
autrement dit Michel David on peut être
totalement pour la loi 21 sans être
islamophobe c'est un peu ça alors
sondage ou pas c'est là que ça il y a
une déroute oui absolument
et être contre sans cette multitude sur
la liste des trucs
pour les parties de position et c'est ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui aussi bien à
Québec
c'est bon pour Monsieur Trudeau c'est
bon pour Monsieur Lego mais c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué pour les parties
de position à Québec aujourd'hui on a vu
les libéraux faire disons un virage
assez assez marqué en coréen il y avait
de la bisbée au sein du parti madame
macaron qui est la député doit se
prendre Saint-Louis pouvait se
baignerable que le gouvernement réclame
la démission de Madame
intérimaire avait dit être obligé de
corriger le type de dire ben non c'était
assez insultant ce qu'elle a dit
aujourd'hui ils ont été forcés de
s'aligner sur le gouvernement et de
seconder a fait d'appuyer la motion qui
réclame le débat le départ de Madame
Allia Rabhi et Québec solidaire marche
sur des œufs aussi ils se sont abstenus
monsieur Gabriel bois devoir faire face
d'ici une dizaine de jours à son conseil
national et là-bas c'est loin de faire
l'unanimité ni la loi sur la laïcité ni
les politiques
identitaires du gouvernement Hugo alors
on essaie de ménager de la chauve et le
chou alors tout ça fait que pour
monsieur Legault comme pour Monsieur
Trudeau à Ottawa c'est une excellente
journée oui exactement parce que
Véronique c'est ça du côté de Monsieur
Trudeau puis comme je vous ai disais
c'est clair puis dit même ça va forcer
des discussions difficiles là autrement
dit oui on va reparler de la loi 21 oui
la loi 21 dans son esprit peut être
perçue comme une attaque envers les
musulmans donc ce Trudeau choisit son
son camp si vous voulez monsieur Legault
le sien les libéraux sont
décidés du leur un peu tard et enfin
hier après-midi et Québec solidaire
comme dit Michel Véronique sont un peu
pris sur la clôture mais en même temps
on constate que du côté d'Ottawa aussi
c'est pas totalement noir ou blanc non
plus chez les autres parties le bloc par
exemple on se serait attendu qu'il
appuie Québec aussi mais il François
Blanchet veut rencontrer la dame d'abord
pour pouvoir parler avec elle le NPD de
son côté semble être satisfait des
clarifications puis finalement pierre
Poirier qui lui demande aussi la
démission puis surtout que Justin
Trudeau décide de l'appuyer malgré le
fait que ces ministres Québécois ont
décidé parce que se retrouvent un peu à
platine Écosse étant donné que c'est des
ministres au Québec qui ont décidé de
dire aux autres aussi qui sentaient
blessés là-dedans donc c'est d'ailleurs
Pablo Rodriguez
même aujourd'hui était pas était pas
José Michel totalement rassuré Pablo
avait driguez
on peut être contre la loi de 21 et est
en même temps qu'on des propos qui
généralisent de façon un peu ridicule
toute une société puis un peuple il doit
être très malheureux
tout seul mais là il voit que son chef
lui est tout à fait d'accord avec Madame
moi je pense monsieur Rodriguez va finir
par trouver que oui finalement elle a
pas tout à fait tard il va essayer de
d'arranger ça mais fondamentalement ça
rend beaucoup de députés libéraux
assez inconfortable je dirais mais pour
Monsieur Trudeau je pense que c'est
encore plus intéressant de voir que
Monsieur
poirievre au Canada anglais là c'est pas
sûr que ça position va être tellement
populaire et au Québec je pense pas
qu'il va faire tellement bien parce
qu'en bout de ligne je pense c'est
encore le bloc qui va qui va avoir la
part du lion du vote nationaliste au
Québec alors je pense que Monsieur
Trudeau les vagues que ça peut produire
dans son caucus il est capable de vivre
avec ça
mais c'est quand même rare que l'on voit
des ministres seniors d'un gouvernement
prendre une position qui est contraire à
celle de leur chef qui s'adonnent à être
aussi le premier ministre du pays je
pense que ça faut en prendre note ça
veut dire qu'il y a un malaise qui a été
créé au sein même du Conseil des
ministres de Monsieur Trudeau c'est pas
un malaise qui va s'évaporer à moins que
Madame agawabi nous surprennent et
décide de partir de son propre chef je
sais pas si possible
plus la sérénité autour de moi jeter des
ponts d'infos voilà c'est peu probable
mais c'est toujours possible évidemment
donc vraiment là comme j'étais il y a
vraiment un malaise au Conseil des
ministres et pour Monsieur Trudeau c'est
c'est sûr que politiquement c'est payant
à court terme sur le coup à l'extérieur
du Québec mais si Madame el ghaouabi
demeure et ne peut pas trouver le
moindre interlocuteur qui est dit au
Québec pour men ses propres missions là
dans son nouveau rôle ben ça risque de
devenir peut-être un peu moins payant
pour Monsieur Trudeau au Québec monsieur
Trudeau à la prochaine élection on sait
pas quand elle va avoir lieu mais ils
vont avoir besoin du Québec et il est
populaire au Québec alors il faut faire
attention aussi à ce capital de
sympathie ok Hydro-Québec alors là hein
président du conseil d'administration
grande patronne et numéro 2 monsieur
Fillon je vous fais écouter quelques
extraits aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il
chez Hydro-Québec
moi je trouve que ça brasse pas malade
au Québec je trouve que non seulement le
gouvernement n'a pas de vision sur le
développement l'avenir énergétique qui
est aussi lié à l'avenir économique
après le départ de ce fibrochu un autre
départ d'un haut dirigeant qui était
probablement peut-être très senti
également pour être nommé PDG qui quitte
pendant ce temps-là on voit que le
premier ministre n'empêche pas le
premier ministre mais monsieur fait du
Gabin là d'y aller déclaration à
l'emporte-pièce là ce matin on apprend
que nouveau vice-président qui est aussi
Yankee sous roche les Québécois les
Québécois ont droit de savoir qu'est-ce
qui se passe à la tête d'une de leurs
sociétés
si les gens quittent faut croire qu'ils
sont qui sont ils pensent qu'ils vont
plus heureux ailleurs et comment le
gouvernement explique ça faut avoir
beaucoup de fois en pierre fait du Gabon
pour considérer que la somme des
avantages de ces actions est supérieur à
la somme des désavantages au plan
éthique et au plan des départs
parce que
mon travail
de Québec il jouait une entreprise
québécoise sur chanceux on va recruter
moi je pense qu'il y a pas dangereux
[Musique]
ça par rapport au gouvernement ça par
rapport au départ
il était pressenti en tout cas lui il se
voyait bien numéro 1 Diderot Québec
est-ce que il a su que tu allais pas
être lui il part en sorte jamais ou
peut-être on le sera un jour il était
chez Bombardier lui c'est il a été
arrivé avec l'autre président jacinthe
côté elle était président du Conseil
elle est partie parce que elle a eu 9
d'une grande banque pour présider le
conseil d'administration puis madame
Brochu elle est partie on sait pas
encore totalement pourquoi
José je commence avec vous cette fois-ci
donc c'est quand même trois gros
morceaux qui qui s'en vont
oui oui mais comme vous le dites on sait
pas vraiment les circonstances réelles
en tout cas on soupçonne celle de du
départ annoncé de Madame brossu mais bon
pour les autres et surtout monsieur
finion c'est pas vraiment mais
l'avantage pour le gouvernement le goût
c'est qu'il se retrouve oui avec
peut-être un arbre à quelques semaines
mais pour lui l'ardoise est nettoyée au
sommet d'Hydro-Québec donc
il se rend libre de choisir les
personnes avec lesquelles il va pouvoir
s'entendre en tout cas il va pour que
les deux visions de l'avenir du
développement d'Hydro-Québec plus
s’arrimer ce que j'ai dit ça
suffisamment diplomatique
et on parle on parle de Monsieur fait du
Gabin on parle de monsieur Legault et en
réalité c'est toujours le gouvernement
du Québec qui décide des grandes
orientations d'Hydro-Québec mais
actuellement tous les projets de plus de
5 MW devront être choisis par
Hydro-Québec et en fait par le ministre
alors Monsieur fils Gabin qui a déjà une
tendance disons à manifester ces
préférences quand hier soir des projets
que ça soit à son ministère ou
Investissement Québec là va pouvoir le
faire d'une façon à tout à fait légal et
on peut très certainement penser qu'il
va en profiter je dis pas que ça va être
des mauvais projets mais disons que ça
va être des projets qui vont plaire au
ministre mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
lui-même le reconnu aujourd'hui peut pas
dire oui à tout le monde parce qu'en
effet il manquerait d'électricité plus
vite que prévu Véronique
oui en fait même Hydro-Québec dit que ça
prendrait 13 complexe de la romaine pour
pouvoir répondre à toutes les demandes
de toute façon le gouvernement veut pas
répondre à tous les demandes pierre Fitz
Gabin il le sa vision il veut développer
par exemple la filière batterie là ce
qui est en train de faire c'est de se
donner les moyens de son ambition c'est
sûr qu'à la fin ça va être très
arbitraire comme choix parce que
Hydro-Québec va proposer le gouvernement
va disposer Hydro-Québec va dire ben
voici les projets on a la capacité où on
n'a pas la capacité puis à la fin c'est
le ministre lui-même avec ses collègues
mais lui-même qui va pouvoir dire est-ce
que ça répond à nos critères qui sont
quand même assez larges on s'entend le
critère de dire il va y avoir des
retombées économiques ça va créer des
emplois ça va nous amener des revenus
fiscaux puis à la fin mais finalement
c'est lui qui décide donc c'est ça
pourrait donner des choix politiques
faudra peut-être qu'il fasse attention à
ça merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne
soirée au revoir au revoir
bonsoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI